Lannister Baratheon stop  Tyrel they will just spokes on a wheel  this one's on top then that one's on top  and on and on it spins crushing those on  the ground  [Applause]  I'm not going to stop the wheel  I'm going to break the wheel Stannis  Baratheon has an army at Castle black it  means to take the north this is the time  and I will risk everything winter is  coming  we know what's coming with it we can  learn to live with the wildlands  we can add them to the army of the death  you have a few we are the many  we serve the gods and the gods demand  justice this city  so the rats have nowhere left to hide  I am a queen not a butcher  although us rather butchers don't meet